c'est une idée qui peut paraître
saugrenue et pourtant elle est belle est
bien sérieuse à face à la difficulté
économiques que rencontre aujourd'hui la
france un entrepreneur avance une idée
pour sortir le pays de la crise la vente
d'un joyau national stéphane distinguin
pdg de la société fabernovel a en effet
évoqué l'idée que la france puisse
revendre sa joconde peinte par léonard
de vinci pour la modique somme de 50
milliards d'euros une vente qui pourrait
permettre de renflouer les caisses de
l'état
si cette idée peut paraître étonnante
elle est pourtant très sérieuse
l'entrepreneur imagine qu'il pourrait
être intéressant de se séparer de
plusieurs oeuvres majeures pour relancer
l'économie nationale
une idée qui devrait sans doute pas
séduit grand monde quand on sait que ce
joyau a aujourd'hui une valeur
inestimable et que le louvre est
aujourd'hui en partie grâce à ce tableau
le musée le plus visité au monde
alors selon vous la france doit-elle
vendre la joconde pour sauver l'économie
alors allez valérie benaïm ma chérie non
non je pense que la france va trouver
d'autres solutions que vendre la joconde
à quand on a commencé à vendre par
exemple savez les châteaux en a brandi
des chaussures aux saoudiens ou chinois
etc
tout le monde a dit ça y est l'étape
dilapide le patrimoine c'est honteux
maintenant on voudrait carrément vendre
là je compte là je compte pour l'instant
plutôt à kehl à quel montant la
maîtresse est illisible estimable et par
ailleurs c'est voir c'est voir vraiment
le le court terme parce que la jeune
ronde ça ramène beaucoup d'argent ce
n'était pas simplement les gens qui vont
au louvre c'est les gens qui viennent en
vacances qui vont justement loose mais
qui vont à l'hôtel qui vont dans nos
restaurants
ils vont dans nos bars qui vend dans nos
magasins et donc qui relancent aussi
notre économie donc quand les touristes
vont revenir la joconde à faire revenir
de l'argent
donc je pense que c'est la voie la voie
revoir vraiment le le vert dans ce cadre
après un mauvais président mais dans ce
cas-là approuvant tout quoi et puis
après si non mais après tout doit
disparaître et où on enlève franchement
on en cause trop mots comment même pas
ça vous allez voir que l'atelier des
influenceurs qui vont la joconde non
mais ça ça ne va pas